c'est un jour que ces jeunes talents ne
sont pas prêts d'oublier
dix huit enfants ont participé à la
deuxième édition du concours de chant du
cabaret du bout des prêts à cerner la
ville samedi dernier ils ont chanté
devant un jury composé de professionnels
de la télévision
on va essayer d'apprécier au mieux la
performance de chacun des enfants
les enfants sont divisés en trois
catégories d'âge parce que forcément on
peut pas comparer une performance fait
par un enfant de six ans avec celle d'un
enfant de 14 ou 15 ans et mener de bruit
déjà pour certains auraient bu et il ya
des gens qui peuvent chanter moyennement
bien là mais dont on sent qu'ils ont qui
peuvent avoir quelque chose ou dans la
personnalité ou dans effectivement le
futur timbre de voix une bonne occasion
de découvrir le monde du spectacle le
concours proposé des prix adaptés aux
gagnants de chaque catégorie
le premier prix est un enregistrement
studio pour pouvoir éventuellement
enregistré la chanson qui sera faite par
le gagnant le deuxième prix et la
possibilité d'aller dans une dans une
émission de télé vu qu'on a des parrains
et maintenant une marraine qui
éventuellement pourraient nous donner la
possibilité d'ouvrir l'envers du décor
donc voilà et puis le troisième prix
c'est la possibilité aux petits d'aller
voir un spectacle sur paris qui est
inquiétant one man show pour enfants si
les jeunes participants avaient la
pression de la scène certains n'oublient
pas que le concours pour leur servir de
tremplin à de vastes c'est le rêve de
tout le monde alors ça c'est
à schwedt entraînements les enfants ont
offert aux spectateurs un véritable show
et certains sont déjà prêts à revenir
l'année prochaine
ces débats organisés
[Applaudissements]